welcome to this video playing doctor
bulky ok Germany did I play at plate
ones winning let's see yeah I'll go for
this for the English Defence leading to
usually sharp positions like that let's
see should be this f5 this is this is
already quite a good line for black it's
not like an advantage but quite nice
this now makes perfect sense to have
delayed the night on and then this is
just blundering really I can just take
it yeah but it's quite amazing often
you'll get this get this on the board
like it's just a rook up here but it's
some of course still a bit tricky
because you have this bed king position
there are lines like that but in those
lines black cam is not able to play king
evade this is the big difference you
have with the bishop already out on
before that Queen age 5 can be answered
by King evade and here he really does
not have a great attacking continuation
i will take the rook here next smooth
unless it takes only 60 then I'll
recapture to make sure that I'm not
mated on f7 it's a bit late to think now
really you do or you have sacrificed the
rook already yeah that happens really
often people play very very committed
stuff like here sacrificing a look and
only afterwards they think if it's
really working bit late um let's one
let's think briefly now here i can even
flick and Knight f6 here
no drawback right here just 9006 getting
this this temple and then I'll take the
rook okay yarn ig6 but i can i can
return and exchange here easily it's
it's a whole rook that I'm up take okay
let's let's think about it for a moment
if i take 96 and there's even King g8 I
mean really nothing going on Jack 96 i
cannot i can take it but i thought that
this is a simple solution getting the
king 2 h8 and still a piece up here and
now yeah this check your jacket check
looks looks like a good move if I play
Bishop you for now i get this Bishop
into the game with temple Bishop takes
Queen takes is very convincing
yeah so probably needs to retreat it
then just 96 yeah yeah i can i can take
here and play Queen III Queen a 3m I'm
the one attacking here check check after
that community checkmate I'm taking
taking another exchange yeah I had this
line beforehand blitz games like resign
it's just like immediately losing this
is thus capture him it's a big
difference to to this position if you
look at this what can also play this f5
and now you can take as this oops EF
Bishop g2 check here I cannot go to
await this is the big difference and I
need to play g6 and then you can take
and this is a line that's that's
probably good for white it's not super
clear it has a reputation of being
losing from black but maybe I am if you
are completely insane and have lots of
type on you and you can try to make it
work black and here actually our instead
of taking has to play a check after
which nights is free leads to the game
and lose this so why it must play king
at one which also covers this and then
black can just play this position with
nine f6 and it's totally murky on in the
game with with this insert it I'm here
white must protect you for snow no way
around it normally why I give this check
and then Queenie to write F 6 or you can
you can also click we need to
immediately not provoking g6 it's only a
slight difference
and this is the way I'm in his plate and
something like that with about equal
equal player black has some counter play
here always on them on the F file like
this like this it's a bit as well as
weird as it sounds a bit like in the
Solian sometimes this f farlis the
counter play and why term really does
not have anything particularly great iam
93 m in general is not not a very
testing move because of Bishop before I
think Bishop d3 is really much stronger
it's a much stronger move 93 belief is
already equal to be honest why time
really does not have a good alternative
you can play f3 but after that black has
various good lines the toughest being at
five after the caption night h6 it's a
very very aggressive but after this
night f5 or threatening Queen to h4 and
this leads to very very tricky play
where white must be yeah really
knowledgeable arm super alert
technically to survive this so it was a
quick game some a bit of an additional
quite quick opening so II hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching